مخاطر الاحتباس الحراري اكبر مما كان
متوقعا بحسب تقرير اصدره فريق دولي تابع
للامم المتحده هذا التقرير النهائي يجمع
سته تقيمات علميه واشار الى ان ثلاثه
اجيال ستشهد تفاقم الازمه وهم مواليد عام
1950 وحتى مواليد عام 2020 النتائج التي
توصل لها العلماء اظهرت انها درجات
الحراره ارتفعت منذ عام
1970 بشكل اسرع من ارتفاعها خلال اي فتره
تضم 50 عاما على مدار الالفي عام الماضيه
واصبحت درجه حراره سطح الارض الان على
بدرجه وعشر الدرجه المئويه مما كانت عليه
في حقبه ما قبل الصناعه التقرير الدولي
مشاهدينا توقع ان يستمر تسلسل الاحداث
المناخيه المتطرفه المدمره كالتي شهدناها
العام الماضي بما في ذلك الفيضانات
والحرائق والجفاف
استمرت في الارتفاع الى او في 2022 ولكن
يجب ان تنخفض بمقدار النصف تقريبا بحلول
عام 2030 حتى يكون لدى العالم اي امل في
الحد من الاحترار العالمي الى درجه ونصف
مئويه ولتحقيق صافي بعثات صفريه يتطلب ذلك
خفضا كبيرا في استخدام الفحم والنفط
والغاز ومحاوله الانتقال الى مصادر الطاقه
المتجدده تقرير اللجنه الدوليه المعنيه
بتغير المناخ خلص الى ان العقبه الاكبر
امام الوصول للاهداف هي قله الرغبه لدى
الجهات السياسيه وان البشره هم المتسببون
بهذه الظاهره وهم من يملكون الادوات
اللازمه للحد من تغير المناخ